hello everyone and welcome back on
today's episode we are going over some
mid-game tactics we've already taught
you a bit about basics and a little bit
about the early game
but now it's time to get past that and
get to that victory
joining us today is holo who is a
hyperscape founder does a ton of awesome
hyperscape content
and streams and has even been a part of
the twitch rivals hyperscape tournaments
so we're going to be learning all the
magic from him today
and you're not going to want to miss it
welcome to the pod
so now that we have already figured out
the early game it's time to get to
not only the mid game but all the things
that come with it like the sectors and
the map and making sure you have
your loadout maximized so holo from your
point of view what are the
important things to know about the mid
game before you even get into any of
those advanced tactics
yeah so mid game is the point where the
zones have collapsed a little bit more
and you're going to be nearby a lot more
teams than you were
in the early beginnings of the game so
things start to get a little bit more
dangerous particularly if you're a
player who likes to try to avoid
fighting it starts to become a little
bit more inevitable so this is
the section of the game where you really
need to make sure that you've been
prioritizing finding the load up that
you're most comfortable with
that you can stand and fight with
because otherwise if you're out of your
elements you are going to be forced to
take fights more than likely so
you need to make sure that you're giving
yourself a fighting chance by having
properly leveled weapons and properly
leveled up hacks
also in the mid game you have to worry
about these sectors once they start
closing in on you and collapsing
it can really change the state of the
game so are there any tips behind the
sectors specifically that you can give
to our viewers one thing that makes
hyperscape unique and different from
other battle rails that we currently
have available is that unlike those
other brs where it's a constantly
shrinking circle
hyperscape has a different closing
sector mechanic
where you have the different building
districts that make up the 100 urban
environment map
uh essentially disappearing or
collapsing and so that can make your
rotation pass a little bit more
unpredictable
it can create uh different choke points
that you'd often are able to avoid
with the the more standard circle
mechanic um so it's really important to
always be keeping an eye on your map and
being aware
of what sort of route you might have to
be taking
uh for the next rotation because in
hyperscape sometimes your route is
basically determined for you
and you have to be prepared to fight
your way through to get to the next safe
zone
and once you do get stuck out into a
completely collapsed
sector you're pretty much out in the
open with no cover whatsoever
how does that change the way that you
want to stay away from those areas
your hacks are your best friends having
some sort of mobility hack such as
teleport or maybe even slam
to try and close the distance between
you and the next safe zone
things like invisibility are wonderful
even if you do get spotted you are able
to break line of sight by going
invisible for about five seconds
sometimes you can't break line of sight
maybe you need something like armor
uh just to soak some damage from both
the the damage that the sector does
or from enemy teams shooting at you but
honestly
the best way to make sure that you're
not in a bad spot
trying to rotate to the next safe zone
is to make sure that you rotate early
okay so let's talk about some more
advanced sector strategies
because now we know how dangerous they
can be
but you can also use that to your
advantage whether you are
trying to get people from coming out of
a collapsing sector and stopping them
before they get to safety
or trying not to be on the other end of
that so are there any strategies you can
share on
gatekeeping sectors that are closing or
vice versa trying to avoid getting gate
cuts
the unique mechanic of collapsing
districts means that sometimes there's
only one safe area to travel through
so if you're if you're set on
gatekeeping find one of those choke
points
and then just sit on top of a rooftop
there's going to be a rooftop and you're
going to be able to maximize your
visibility
your lines of sight so that means that
any opponent that's too slow
rotating into the next safe zone
basically doesn't have much of a
fighting chance against you unless they
have some of the mobility hacks that i
mentioned previously
but otherwise you can put a lot of teams
in a really awkward position
by just setting up on a rooftop again
maximizing lines of sight
and gatekeeping in that way something
else that is really unique about
hyperscape
is the echo system can you tell us any
tips on
maybe reviving safely or
getting your loot back after you get
revived because
not all the time are you able to get
revived next to the loot that you just
dropped sometimes you have to travel
really far to get revived and you're
stranded in the middle of nowhere with
no loot to be found what are the best
ways to rebuild your loadout after you
get revived
yeah the echo system is honestly one of
my favorite revive mechanics in a battle
royale so far because it does
keep everybody on your team involved um
and
again the mid game is where a lot more
eliminations tend to happen because
you're just more densely packed with
other players
so if you or a teammate gets eliminated
and you need to go for a revive system
that's often just a game sense call
you're likely going to die near
an enemy tombstone that you can be
revived on just because you were
probably
in an engagement with another team so
there might be tombstone nearby
either from that squad even fighting or
just a nearby squad
that's just a sort of game sense
decision that your teammates have to
make
is it worth the risk reward of trying to
stick a rez in the open
or in the middle of a gunfight you're
you say hey this team
you know got third party they're
fighting maybe we can try and sneak this
rez really quickly and i can get my guns
back that are right there
but in some cases there's just too many
other teams on top of you
so in that case you have to make the
call to maybe back up to a revive that's
two 300 meters away and you don't know
what kind of loot is back there
if that happens you really just have to
there's there's likely very little hope
that you're going to get your loadout
back
and you just have to kind of pick up
whatever's on the ground sometimes you
have to take a minute after getting
revived as well to try to find unloaded
buildings you can look for buildings
that haven't had
the doors and windows broken off of them
yet um you can search around for the
little yellow
loot chests that are hidden around the
map it's really just a game sense
decision
again sometimes it's worth trying to
stick that five second res in the open
in the middle of a gunfight sometimes
you can pull it off and grab your gear
right away but
sometimes if you're playing for the long
the long term you have to make that
decision to try and back up two or three
hundred meters and just play the rest of
the game with
subpar loot until you can kill a team
and take their good stuff
we're not always able to get our weapons
maxed out right away
sometimes you might run up on a weapon
that is already maximized and
what are some of the decisions you have
to make in choosing something that's
leveled up
over trying to get something leveled up
and trying to make that you know the
best call at the moment
yeah as you said it's really important
to make sure that your weapons and your
hacks
are fully leveled when you venture into
the mid game because other teams are
going to have
fully leveled weapons and items their
damage output is probably going to be
higher than yours if you don't as well
sometimes you have to make that decision
to just drop what you're more
comfortable with
and take the item that has the faster
cooldown that lets you be more
aggressive or have the option to
disengage from a fight more frequently
if you feel like you're being pressured
too much likewise let's
say you find a weapon that's fully fused
i feel like with weapons sometimes it's
more important to take the fully fused
one because
if you do encounter a solid team of
players who have fully fused weapons and
your weapons aren't gold as well
it's very hard to win that damage race
against them so you also need to stand
on equal terms at least in terms of the
damage that you're doing
with every single shot that you land
obviously having your weapons
maxed out and your hacks ready for
action
is important but there were some new
things added into hyperscape upon
release after the beta
like the magnet hack that we mentioned
previously
and there's also some weapons that have
kind of risen the ranks so to say
in terms of popularity among the
community and kind of shaking up the
meta of hyperscape
so from your perspective polo how do you
feel about how these hacks have changed
the game
and what are your thoughts on the
current meta of hyperscape
as far as the meta goes in terms of
hacks and weapons
the the one that's obviously a big point
of discussion right now is the mammoth
shotgun
you ha you can't deny the power of the
man the shotgun it is one of the best if
not the best weapon in the game right
now simply because it has such
chunky burst damage potential
hyperscapes focuses on
survivability you have 120 hp health
pool you have all these different hacks
that lets you disengage from a fight
safely if you feel the need to
but sometimes just opening up a gunfight
with a crack from a from a mammoth
shotgun for
almost 100 damage just even if you don't
kill that player outright
in a single shot you're gonna [ __ ]
that player and it makes it extremely
hard for them to stand and take the
fight
essentially forcing them to try to
disengage and run away and then you
throw into the mix things like magnet
that basically say
no you have to stay here and fight me
and so that's why the the the meta has
become very swingy in terms of people
carrying
heavy burst damage weapons like the
mammoth shotgun like the riot one
so that's why we see the meta at least
at high levels on hyperscape pc
uh more oriented towards those style of
weapons
alright we've gone over a ton of tactics
we've learned a bunch of strategies
and now it's time to have a couple of
laughs we gathered up
all of the community plays that we
thought hola would enjoy today and stuff
that kind of
fits on topic with some of the things
we've been talking about and
we want you to check them out so go for
it
so we've got a player with slam and
invisibility honestly one of the meta
loadouts in terms of hacks right now
gives you a lot of aggression
and a lot of disengagement power and man
the hex fire is just
absolutely shredding is that a quad kill
feed i see there with the hex fire
i don't know what to say to other than
that that's putting that 150 round
magazine to really good use
this is from cross 516 on reddit so
we've got the shotgun in the komodo
interesting build here again more chunky
burst damage you don't see the komodo
much
putting the komodo to use up close is an
interesting call since it does do reduce
damage
wow okay i was just about to say it does
reduce damage at close range but at long
range it deals out a lot and that was
an impressive long range era ground to
aerial shot with the komodo you really
just don't see it used in that capacity
it's
much more common for those roles to be
reversed where the player with the
komodo
is firing from the sky down on a player
down on the ground it's just easier to
use because
you can hit the ground next to the
player that splash damage takes over
if you're shooting at someone who's in
the air you have to hit them and that
was a really impressive precise shot
with the komodo
it's like we've got magnet i see a
magnet which is great
we have mama shotgun and the protocol
sniper rifle but he's got the protocol
out indoors which means he's going for a
clip all right there's the magnet play
wow the no scope
with the sniper rifle connects finishing
him off in the back with the mammoth
shotgun and the emote wave
i le i love it you know that's that's
there's a little bit of cheese
with that you know using the sniper
indoors plus the magnet plus the emote
at the end
hats off i love that kind of content
that was great we could not let you
leave here without analyzing a play of
your own
now we grabbed this clip from one of
your recent youtube videos because
it was just that awesome there's a ton
of people everywhere but
that didn't scare you one bit so we're
gonna need you to break this one down
for us
so this was from a recent highlights
video i released on youtube
so this particular segment of this video
just has to do
with uh illustrating the power of the
sky breaker one of my favorite weapons
since
playing this uh behind closed doors you
know the early tech test days and things
like that
this weapon is slept on in my opinion it
really allows you to
chunk multiple enemies at a time and
when it's gold and you're firing it from
the range that i'm firing it at over 20
meters it's doing more than
half it's taking away more than half
their health with a single hit so
really all you see here is me using it
to soften up targets and then drop in on
top of them
switch to a higher dps weapon like the
ripper just to put in those finishing
shots
uh just wiping out a whole lot of people
in a short time frame alright thank you
so much
holo for joining us and for spreading
some knowledge
to the viewers are there any final words
you'd like to give
fans if anyone's out there is interested
in learning how to play the game better
i i stream on twitch almost every single
day twitch.tv holo you can find my
youtube channel at youtube.com
hologames where i upload not only
gameplay highlights by tips and tricks
to help you learn how to play
the game at a higher level how to
improve
yeah i just appreciate everyone always
supporting the content hanging out and i
i love seeing
all these high-level players in the
community as people get their hands on
it and learn how to play the game and
all the excitement around you know
improving it's
it's so much fun just love to see it
awesome well thank you again
and for everyone watching don't forget
that you can submit your own clips on
twitter using hashtag hyperscape so
feel free to submit your clips for next
week's episode because we're going to be
going over some late game tactics and
everything that comes along with that
you're not going to want to miss it
now before you go don't forget we have
another
memory shard hint for you check it out
[Applause]
you